although probably be another coolest
bubble but in the meantime where I'm
spending more of my time is in health
care and specifically personalized
health I was talking about this
yesterday there's there's kind of
professionally generated content and
then there's user-generated content
which was hot last year and is now may
be cold but what's really interesting is
user sort of like user data and because
it's about specific users of course all
these privacy and control issues apply
but whether it's your genome or your
personal buying habits or just your
information that that's going to be
really really interesting I think a lot
of the next generation of tools many of
them are going to be in one way or
another mirrors tools that now allow
people to look at information about
themselves their trips their their books
their collections their financial
information their genome their health
information and that to me is the next
exciting area
23 which I'm on the board of we give
people information about their own
genomes and then they can if they like
compare themselves to family members or
two people they know but comparing
yourself to someone you know who's not a
relative is probably going to be pretty
boring because you're unlikely to have
much overlap at all you can find out
information about various inherited
things everything from eye color and I
was just looking at some of these ears
the other day and you know ears are
actually very different from person to
person to are you likely to get
different kinds of cancer what's your
circadian rhythm that kind of stuff and
you can see your ancestry which is also
kind of interesting so there's if you
were unkind you could say some of this
appeals to narcissism but yeah so it
does
you